i i remember making how do when i was so
young to uh
like a macklemore song oh it was a
magical war song it was wild man it was
wow all right my name is nico haraga
and we're going to play teenage trivia
here at the kelly clarkson show
okay so my teenage crush i think
well i had a i had a few say one was
professor mcgonagall
another was hal from hell's moving
castle these are all made up characters
dude
uh uh emma watson emma what emma watson
yeah yeah we'll go with them a lot
for right now but yeah yeah which emma
watson was it like harry potter
uh no like not hermione but like
but emma watson as emma watson
for sure yeah
the best relationship advice that i've
gotten would have to be
yolo oh dude i don't know
yo you only live once man you know
just keep it keep it pushing you know if
you're in love you're in love
you know just keep it keep it going man
just
i mean the best relationship advice that
i could give myself would just be trust
your heart
right so yeah
oh in high school my bff would describe
me as
maybe like rambunctious maybe maybe like
misfit
or or or simply a simplest way to put it
my bff in high school described me as a
troublemaker
to say the least yeah i got grounded
well honestly my parents weren't really
tripping off
grounding me um
i say i got scolded
for just about anything i do on any
weekend
[Music]
first time i ever made out to i i feel
like it was some like
bay area song at like some house party
somewhere like maybe some too short or
something
but honestly like that that's just what
i'm guessing but
like a memory for sure i i remember
making how to do when i was so young to
uh
like a macklemore song oh it was a
magical war song it was wild man it was
wild
but yeah macklemore we did back
oh i lied to my teacher no i don't ever
lie to my teacher
i think the biggest lie i've told my
teacher
is just like yo can i use the bathroom
i'll be back in
a minute it's just a quick peek and then
i'll just do laughs around the school
and just be gone for like 30 minutes and
cruise back and be like
dude got caught up you know like hectic
p
or something like that i don't know but
yeah i don't really lie to my teachers
my perfect partner would be someone that
whatever this person is i just hope i
mean i simply
put it is just make me laugh be stoked
on life
have you looking forward to waking up
the next day encouraged me to keep doing
me you know yeah you know
it's right there with me mindset right
same kind of mindset we're right there
right next to each other
yeah oh my guilty pleasure
is binge eating ramen noodles
[Music]
that's my guilty pleasure man
[Music]
one thing i wish people knew about me oh
yo
i don't smoke weed i'm not a stoner i
don't smoke weed
i see even you were like what dude
yeah no i'm not a stoner i people always
ask yo come come
i'ma smoke you out i'm smoking no tried
that when i was a little
grommet for a couple years
no mass i haven't smoked for like
10 years or something man yeah i don't
smoke i'm not a stoner
thank you guys for watching catch me on
the kelly clarkson show
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help